that's awesome
but
the uh the final
question we had was from william
lombombard who basically how do you go
from set up punchline
to stories
[Music]
so i think
uh
with like i think it was uh
what's
who's the country guy we just watched
this special we just talked about it a
couple weeks ago
country guy
i say country guy just
um
i'm forgetting his name oh my god
we just did a
breakdown of a special
not earthquake
no
uh all i know is steve just gave us a 20
super chat oh my
let's go
honey dinner's on me tonight
it's on me
let's go
right
um jeff foxworthy how did i forget that
yes thanks jordan jordan jeff foxworthy
thank you steve as well
so jeff foxworthy
uh
and you're in the first time that you
interviewed talked about how he does
stories of just like writing out the
stories
like just as they are and then going
back in and adding the funny parts it's
kind of like how ron white does him too
right just write the story as it is and
then add funny parts all the way in
between but you got to be real with the
story first and then you add the funny
components um that's how you take
storytelling
onto the stage more is
it's not set up premise punch kind of
thing any longer it's more here's a
story now you add the funny inside of
the entire story because you can't wait
for the end of it to do the punchline
it's got to be funny all the way through
yeah that's that's definitely
uh what i heard chris titus say as well
who i don't know if if people have not
seen chris titus i mean
he's he sells out theaters he's done a
lot of things i think he's still
underrated murder
the last two comedy specials that he did
on youtube were spectacular
he does like he's a storyteller and it's
like every line is a laugh and what what
he said
um is like he writes the story out as it
happened not trying to be funny
and then like he said every detail
is like the setup for a punchline and
that's how he packs in
so many different jokes now i will also
say
that there another way if you're going
from like one-liners to storytelling
what i found in personal experience
because i personally haven't
like written out a story and then like
gone back and tried to punch it up how
my the the biggest like stories i have
like crying at my wedding is probably my
first real attempt
at like a story
but
the actual story
is a bunch of individual bits
that add up to a story so it's like i
have
the story is like me getting married
planning the wedding and then the
wedding and crying at my wedding which
yoshi was there yoshi was the dj at my
wedding i am so glad there wasn't video
in hindsight i maybe wish there was
but it's like me crying a suspicious
amount is is like part of the joke
but it's a bunch of small individual
jokes that i then just organize in a way
that's more of like a story but yeah
a way to build a one-liner up even more
is just like if you have a one-liner
then it's like okay
adding tags to it
make it more of a story than just like a
one-liner as well
sure yeah and i've done a couple of
stories i've got a couple of stories but
to your point it's like
i i think of it as here's an interesting
story i tell a story about like
an hoa that i was a part of that was
just like wild and crazy
and
like when i first tell it white claws
everywhere
but like i had i was a part of the hoa
that was just like crazy but as i tell
the story
and i when i wrote it down the first
time i did exactly what titus did just
write it out the way that it was and
then i started looking at it like
specifically like each line
where is the joke where is the funny in
each one of these things and so now that
i tell it it's probably there's probably
a joke every
one to two sentences in some form or
fashion as i'm telling a story and i
think that's the key because then when i
get to the crescendo of like the big
punch line
they didn't have to wait to laugh they
were laughing all the way through so
then when the punch
it's like oh yay they're like the
audience feels rewarded by it so i think
yeah i think that just that premise of
just
tell the story as it is and then add the
funny after you tell the story yeah
simple sweet
but it works
and then yeah and then on the other side
of it if you're writing one-liners and
you're trying to turn a one-liner into a
story
it's just expand it out like if the
one-liner is about let's just say
one-liner about crying at your wedding
okay bringing in different points of
view can start to build into a story of
like you're talking about crying at your
wedding okay how did your wife react to
it how did your father-in-law react to
it how did the efficient react to it
like
looking at the one-liner from like 360
degrees can help you to actually start
to build it out from a single line into
an entire story so
yeah there's a talking about ways to do
it
talking about what the dj
thought about you crying
while you were crying thought about what
the dj actually saw
and catching the dj's eye as you're
crying
i remember i remember at one point i was
wiping my tears with my vows i was just
like
[Music]
it's wild that's
yeah it was well abby asked how do you
develop that final massive punch line uh
i think big thing for that massive final
punch line
is just working out
that you have jokes all the way through
the punch line massive punchline is just
like a normal setup premise punch kind
of thing
but
because your whole story is the premise
the punchline is going to hit because
you've already set up everything else so
it's just like having a whole bunch of
setup punchlines set up punchline setup
punches on set up punchlines throughout
your entire story but it's all thematic
beautiful